hi i'm priyanka vargaria and this is ai
simplified where we learn to make our
data
useful in this video we are predicting
the future
that sounds like i'm an astrologer but
not really
we are going to predict a different kind
of future influenced by
data yeah you're right we are covering
forecasting models what they are and how
to create them
in vertex forecast but before we dive
into it
what are some of the applications of
forecasting say you're a retailer
and you need to predict product demand
or sales
or you're a call center manager and
you're predicting the call volume to
hire more representatives
you're a hotel chain predicting hotel
occupancy for next season or you're a
hospital and forecasting bed occupancy
you get the idea forecasting data sets
come
in many shapes and sizes there are
univariate data sets where we observe
a single variable over a period of time
for example you can think about weather
data or
airlines data even though it's just one
variable
sometimes this is all that you need to
forecast your data into the future
you can see clear patterns the seasonal
peaks
and also the trends in that data more
often
we are faced with multivariate data sets
where you have historical
observations of the variables you're
forecasting and
other related time series these are
often referred to
as covariance and covariance because the
value varies with the target variable
these related time series can be very
helpful to forecast your
target variable and maybe for example
you're plotting rain
versus umbrella sales versus uber rides
now we all know how taxis can be hard to
get when it suddenly starts to rain so
as an owner of a taxi company
i can use the weather forecast to
anticipate the higher demand
in my cars and bring the cars online
be aware that not all co-variants are
useful
even if they correlate strongly with
your target variable
some common examples of covariance used
in retail forecasting are
holidays third-party forecasts such as
weather
and you can have planned promotions foot
traffic to the stores and so on
up next we are going to look at
forecasting algorithms
now here are the algorithms we can use
for forecasting
the most popular methods today are
statistical methods which are also
called
as classical methods there are many
types of statistical models
including arima models that are being
used for most popular use cases
now google offers an advanced arima plus
model
with bqml which is bigquery ml
the other class is machine learning
models like
various tree based methods and neural
networks
now these deep learning models have been
gaining a lot of popularity for
forecasting applications over the past
few years
now obviously there's still a lot of
debate on when to apply which methods
but it's becoming increasingly clear
that neural networks are here to stay
for forecasting applications
these methods perform fairly well across
a broad range of forecasting problems
and particularly
well when dealing with forecasting newer
item demands
and these are called cold starts and
forecasting cold starts on items with
limited
or varying historical data now deep
learning models
cross learn across very large groups of
related time series with
varying lengths and missing data the
good news is that you don't really need
to know exactly which architecture to
use
because vertex forecast does that for
you
now we can build forecasting models in
vertex using
advanced automl algorithms for neural
network architecture search
now we automated the pre-processing of
your time series data
and instead of fumbling into data types
and transformations you can just
load your data into the data set in
vertex ai
and auto ml would automatically apply
those common transformations and even
engineer features for you and required
required for modeling now most
importantly
we could evaluate hundreds of models in
parallel to find the right architecture
for your particular data set and this
requires a lot of computational
resources
but because we can run all these trials
in parallel
we're still able to find the best model
and tune it to your particular data set
in the fraction of time
it typically takes for a traditional
method and of course we can assemble the
best
model and together to ensure the model
is stable across a wide range of
predicted outputs
now how does all this work let's jump
into the console and see
from our vertex ai dashboard we create a
new tabular data set
we can see there is an option for
forecasting
you may be curious if you can apply a
regression model
to your time series data now the
difference between them
is that regression and classification
the target's predicted value depends
only on the values of the feature
columns in the same row
now in forecasting the target's
predicted value also depends on the
context values of the target
and the features now we will see more on
this further in the demo
in regression and classification
problems the output
is one value but as you can imagine
in forecasting problems the output is
a sequence of values now let's select
forecasting here and proceed
we are using the iowa liquor sales
public data set available
in bigquery now it consists of wholesale
liquor purchases in united states state
of iowa since
2012 and we can preview this data here
for the purpose of this demo i have
already done some
basic data pre-processing to group the
purchases
by day and we will use a csv extract
from the bigquery table
now back in our data set let's import
the data from our cloud storage bucket
you can also upload the data directly
from your computer
or bigquery table here once the data is
imported
we can configure the model features now
time series identifier column
is to specify what time series a row
belongs to
now every unique combination of key
values defines a different time
series for example here in id
is our time series identifier now if we
need to forecast on multiple time series
such as
product and store levels both of those
could be used as keys
now time column is the identifier such
as
date or days etc why is our sum of
purchases that day and holiday is a
boolean to indicate a holiday
then we can train the model select the
target column
this is the value we are predicting so
in our case it is
sales or the y column we've already set
our
time series identifier and the time
column
so next we need to set the data
frequency
i'm selecting hourly here and setting
the forecasting horizon to
7. this specifies the number of periods
that the model can predict
into the future now historical context
window i'm setting to 30 hours here this
means that the model will
use data from previous 30 hours to make
a prediction
there are trade-offs between shorter and
longer windows
and generally selecting a value between
one to five
times the forecasting horizon is
recommended
now let's check the box to export test
data set to bigquery
we can leave it blank and it will
automatically create a data set and
table in our project within bigquery
now in the training options we can
specify more details about how we would
like to train the model
set these columns to available for new
forecast
because we know this information already
change the optimization objective to mae
or mean average error which is more
resilient to outliers
and because we are working with daily
purchase data that can have
wild fluctuations mae is an appropriate
metric to use here
before we initiate the training set a
budget
in this case one note hour is sufficient
to train the model
now once the model is trained we can
evaluate it
and go to bigquery console to view the
predictions on test data
a new data set is automatically created
where we find the evaluated data items
table to review the predictions
this table has a couple new columns here
now predicted on date column which is
the date that the predictions were made
and predicted y column is the predicted
sales value now finally we would want to
use your model to make predictions
we have an input file in the csv format
on cloud storage and it contains empty
values for the dates to be predicted
along with the historical data
after it is complete we can click on the
batch prediction job to view the details
including the export location we
sent our predictions to bigquery which
we can see here
and the job creates two different files
or tables
one contains any rows with errors and
the other contains predictions
lastly now that we have our batch
predictions ready we can evaluate our
forecasts in data studio which is
google's free data visualization tool
the blue line shows my historical values
and the red lines
are my forecast now looks like the model
picked up on
quite a bit of signal in the data okay
so in this video we learned about
forecasting models what they are and how
to create them
in vertex forecast give this a try
yourself and send me your questions in
the comments below